[MUSIC]
KARL KUSSEROW: I'm Karl
Kusserow, John Wilmerding
Curator of American Art
at the Princeton
University Art Museum.
And we're here today to talk
about one of the great icons
of American art and one of the
great treasures of Princeton
University, Charles Willson
Peale's portrait of George
Washington at the Battle
of Princeton.
The painting dates to 1784.
It is a truly fascinating work
on any number of levels, not
the least of it, it's close
association with Princeton
University as an institution.
So the frame arrives in
Princeton in January of 1761,
enclosing a portrait
of King George II.
It was hung in what was then
the prayer hall,--
It's now the faculty room.
--until the Battle of Princeton,
some 16 years later
when, in 1777, the battle
culminated at the back door,
so to speak, of Nassau Hall.
During the final stages of
the battle, the American
artillery--
And it's known that they were
led by Alexander Hamilton,
though it's unclear whether he
was the one that actually
fired the fateful shot.
--but at any rate, one of those
cannon balls from the
American artillery entered the
prayer hall and destroyed the
portrait of King George II
originally hung in this frame.
There is testimony, which is
accredited that the shot took
off the king's head.
Whether or not that's true, the
portrait was destroyed.
And six years later, Peale's
portrait of Washington went
into the very frame that had
formerly surrounded that of
the other George,
King George II.
So in a wonderful act of
revolutionary symbolism, you
have the portrait of our George,
George Washington
replacing the portrait of King
George II of England, who was
the person who gave Princeton,
then the College of New
Jersey, it's charter.
We're here now in the faculty
room at Nassau Hall, which is
where the portrait that we just
left at the art museum
hung for more than two centuries
Happily, Princeton has in its
possession another portrait of
George Washington as a great
hero, but done in the context
of a battle that had
already been won.
He rests his hand very
proprietorially on a captured
cannon and leans almost in a
jaunty pose, very much at
ease, having won this
great victory.
And that's a very different
effect from the portrait at
the art museum, which shows
the battle still raging.
And the outcome is, in
that case, unclear.
So two portraits very similar
in subject, but taking place
at different times in the
fictive narrative of what's
being shown at the Battle
of Princeton.
[MUSIC]